evidence of how close the world has come
to a nuclear disaster in ukraine
shelling caused this hole on the roof of
a building that houses nuclear fuel and
radioactive waste
here more damage at europe's biggest
nuclear plant seized by russian forces
in march and placed on the front line of
a war zone
a team of international inspectors
braved the dangers to visit the site
last week
the head of the un's nuclear watchdog
led the mission and he wants the world
to know what it found
the hits that this facility has uh
received and that i could personally see
and assess
together with my experts is simply
um
unacceptable we are playing with fire
and something very very catastrophic
could take place he released a report on
how to stop the war in ukraine from
triggering a nuclear catastrophe
a key recommendation was that shelling
on the site and in its vicinity should
be stopped immediately
this requires agreement by all relevant
parties to the establishment of a
nuclear safety and security protection
zone around the zaparisian nuclear plant
the inspectors didn't apportion blame
for the damage suffered so far here but
their report noted the presence of
russian military vehicles such as this
one
it said any vehicles that could
interfere with the safe running of the
plant should be removed
sustaining the supply of electricity
powering the plant was also flagged as
vital
it's been cut off a number of times
raising concerns of a nuclear meltdown
the mayor of the town where the plant is
based fled the area a few months ago
speaking from a nearby city he accused
russia of attacking the facility to
pressure ukraine into pulling back from
an offense of its launch against russian
positions in the south
russia has blamed ukraine for being the
one endangering the facility
but it seems unlikely russian forces
will comply with the report's
recommendations to stop shelling and
effectively withdraw
debra haynes sky news in southern
ukraine